so thank you everyone uh my name is
Edgar Ruiz um I work with the sparkly r
package so um been doing like large
scale implementations that has to do
with implementing r as well um um it
being able to work with SQL and this
case spark and what I'm going to talk
about today is its implementation with a
new kind of spark which is uh spark
connect so I'll start right
there uh with spark connect is something
that started in a very really recent
version of spark uh 3.4 in fact it's so
recent that 3.5 literally came out
yesterday so we're talking about like
that close and with spark connecting not
it's not so much a new way of
implementing like you have like
Standalone or kubernetes or yarn this is
more about how you connect to spark
right so if we were talking about like a
remote way of connecting to spark as it
used to be before that was through
something called Livy and in order for
you for us to use Livy we needed to have
a full on implementation of a yarn based
cluster such as had doop cluster uh to
be able to get take advantage of that
service um which is not ideal in the new
world that we live in where most of our
data is now like S3 buckets right that
all we need right now is not so much a
place to land our data like Hadoop does
but more about where how to process it
right a way to process it easily which
is to spark right so with spark connect
is basically doing that for us where we
can actually have a spark clust
that we can actually interact with uh
remotely right in our laptops we can
easily uh go back and forth and uh
interact with it uh data breaks connect
uh versions uh 13 plus uh is B have a
spark connect is based on that so um
you'll be able to take advantage of it
if you're currently using it or think
about using it so how does it work well
underneath it instead of doing like stup
rate rest apis like used to be with liby
uh SP connect is using uh
grpc um which actually works as that
layer of communication and at this point
I can confidently say that the best way
to interact uh with that gr grpc uh is
through pisar so pisar will use um other
python libraries that uh Implement grpc
and then talk to to uh sparkk uh for the
machine learning stuff which again just
came out yesterday
uh it's going to be done through uh
torch and right now there's like a I
believe one uh machine learning model
implemented in then new version uh so
what about R right what about sparkly R
well because of the implementation
that's going on with py spark uh we made
the call to go ahead and integrate
through that library and in order to do
that we're using the reticulate package
so if you're not familiar with it this
is the package that INR allows us to
integrate with python directly from our
R session uh so we can have to wear
communication with it uh so as you can
see in this little diagram uh you can go
from reticulate to py spark uh into the
spark cluster so the question is okay if
I can do this from reticulate why do I
need sparkly R for well as if you are a
user today uh you can you know that
sparkar does other things right it gives
you that uh interface for deer so you
can use deer commands to interact with
spark you can also use DBI and also the
connection paint as well other uh very
easy to use functions that as data
scientist we use to run models and
things like
that and the other great thing that I'm
very excited about is like once you
start using it you don't have to have
Java installed in your computer anymore
this has been uh the the subject of a
lot of hard hard for a lot of us to have
Java working well because it's all
remote and because it's using this uh
grcp you don't have to worry about that
anymore uh to get started very easy you
would use uh the latest version of SP
as well as uh the way that we chosen to
implement it at this time which is
through an extension package called P
spark C uh that you would install from
um from GitHub uh we hopefully we'll
have this in CR pretty soon uh so all
you have to do is upgrade your sparkly
install it and then to get the python
components that you'll need uh P spark C
gives you a convenience uh function that
will install all the python libraries
that uh you will need to use in order to
to get it working so if you're a python
user already and you're saying ah I
don't need you know the convenience um
you know function I can do it myself
these are the packages that you'll need
uh there is a a requirement for you to
have python 3.9 or above uh and if you
are an our user and the other way around
right like you you don't really want to
mess too much with python that's totally
fine too I feel exactly the same way so
I've gone through the pain of doing all
this and put in all the stuff that you
need in that function if you don't have
3.9 available in your laptop it'll warn
you and it'll give you some tips on how
to how to do your upgrade if you need
to um you can also run uh spark connect
locally uh so this is something that we
kind of used to as we start learning um
spark uh we run spark locally uh and
what it does it start spark and then uh
whenever you do a connection and
actually it stops the service when you
disconnect uh for spark connect it's
going to be a little bit different
you're going to have to start the server
separate and then stop it separate from
your connection uh at this point we can
actually make this function a little B
better a bit more convenient uh we have
it available now and we're definitely
going to be improving it to make it
easier to use and to actually not so
much easier to use but have more
customizations and things that you can
do with it so now we we come to datab
brakes connect right so how does that um
you know connect to um to data brakes
connect so if you're a customer of you
working with h with data brakes before
uh you know you heard data Brak connect
before right that term but now you also
hear the term data connects data brakes
connect V2 so that version two is what
we're talking about now that uh started
with spark 3.4 through the spark connect
that is going to be available in dbr 13
and above um datab bras connect as same
thing is spark connect now you can use
uh your laptop to be able to interact
with spark so you don't have to be
inside the environment inside data
brakes and open our studio there and all
that you can actually do that on on your
laptop and in order to do that today
you're able to do uh to connect you'll
need four things which is the master and
that would be the URL uh for the data
breaks of your organization uh the
cluster ID that you want to work with
also your personal token that you can
also get from data breaks and the method
which would be data breaks uncore
connect uh as opposed to data breaks
Dash connect our data breaks so we try
to make it as confusing as possible for
you and I apologize for that so um but
we have some a lot of warnings that
hopefully will catch you there all right
so the other thing that we want to do is
these two uh environment variables data
bricks host and data briak token are
becoming very standardized right now
across different applications as you
start working with database connect V2
um so sparklyr picks them up so that way
whenever you connect to your cluster you
don't need to set them all up you
basically just provide your cluster ID
and uh your data Brak connect method uh
and of course please please please use
your data Brak token in the environment
variable do not put your credentials in
an open text for your code right
definitely best best
practices um because uh we're able to do
that uh integration directly to ppar
we're getting a lot of nice goodies to
integrate better so this is the unity
catalog where you can see your tables
right uh inside the datab brakes web UI
well now that's inside our studio this
is the first time in sparkly art history
that we're offering more than one layer
used to be that we would stop from table
into a schema now we go the three layers
all the way to matching to what data
bricks does so we can go from a table to
schema to uh catalog and that will make
it where you can be here and have the
exact same um structure navigational
structure that you see inside UC see
right so that way it's a lot easier for
you to be able to find the tables that
you want to in act with and of course
you can also preview the tables if you
need to uh by just clicking on it you'll
see the first, rows so that will that
give you that visual you know first uh
um first look of the
data um also accessing the catalog data
is very easy now um DB player has a a
new function called in catalog so you
may be aware of in schema this in
catalog gives you from a supposed in
schema with those two levels in catalog
will do the three levels right so as you
see you have the three uh samples to
invoice taxi to trips you basically put
that in the same order inside the
function call and you're good to go um
that creates the pointer to the table
then now will uh whenever you just call
the variable just going to bring you the
top 10 rows right because uh DB player
and sparkly R does have those guard
rails that prevent you from or me I
don't say you as in general but me from
be able to when I do this download the
entire like billion records right it you
can use those goodies again from the
stuff that we wrap around all this other
um communication with spark uh once you
have your um your table excuse me your
pointer you can um use deep player as we
do today uh the same commands right
you're able to uh push all that
computation to the cluster so instead of
you having to download the billions of
records and then do the summarization in
your laptop you can just write deer as
you would you treat trips just as if it
was a table that you have locally and
what it does um in the you know in the
background is that it will translate
your um your deer commands into SQL
right so all the computation all the
aggregation is happen remotely and
you're just getting back the results
which is the exact ideal way that you
want to deal with these kinds of data uh
database and uh big data backends right
if you want to see the the query that
you're getting you can use show query
and that will U provide you the that
that
query also coming soon I'm very excited
to talk about this um this is the first
time we're actually showing it um as far
as the work that we're doing inside um
uh the datab breakes webui again uh you
have where you can manage the clusters
right where you can start and stop a
cluster and be able to uh basically get
the information that you need in order
to connect to it well in a coming soon
version of poset workbench will be able
to have that same ability inside a new
pain a data bricks pain uh that pain
will match to what you see
today in the in the web UI where you can
start stop a cluster and you can also
expand the details a specific cluster
and see the same information that that
you would see in uh in the web UI right
so that way again you start in our
studio and you end in our studio right
so we start with the catalog and now
with the with being able to um uh
administer the clusters by starting and
stopping and this is kind of like my
favorite feature uh because now the
first time that you connect to a cluster
right uh again remember the only thing
that you would need would be the cluster
ID well um the very genius folks that
working on this solution which is not me
by the way this is the IDE folks uh have
put a a copy button right there uh for
you to get your cluster ID which then
you just paste it in your in your uh in
your code and you're good to go right no
U no problem you start and end our
studio and once you connect for the
first time right then the connection
pain kind of takes over from what you've
been using before um you'll be able to
have that connection uh so you end your
work and you come back tomorrow you'll
have it right there you click on it it
shows you the code that you used to
connect and then once you say yes I want
to connect you go right back to the UN
need catalog so I mean this is this is
really exciting for me because uh I'm
sure a lot of folks who are working
today uh with this environment uh will
make see a lot improvements when it
comes to what we call Quality of Life As
far interacting with it uh some
additional information um there's some
limitations right now with spark 3.4 and
3.5 when it comes to spark connect um
excuse me uh so what we support as I
mentioned before we have de plier and
DBI apis uh the vote command will work
uh the connection pain like I showed uh
also the uh personal uh authorization
token will work we are actually also
working another thing I'm kind of glad
to to announce on oo that will work
directly from
workbench uh and also the most of the
read and write commands work today was
not supported of course especially in
3.4 which is what's uh like kind of like
right now G available uh is uh ml
functions SDF functions and tid and
although this is kind of sort of not
right because pivot longer is available
now although not all arguments so if you
want to try an existing pivot longer
code that you have in uh spark connect
um it will not ignore the the arguments
it will just tell you that it's not
supported so it's safe for you to try
out um also you can access the entire
API right so sparklyr will not have
everything uh all the time but you
should be able to access everything as
opposed to how it was before that you
had to wait on me to go in and make the
argument change because Park from one
version to the next add a new argument
now you have to wait for me to add it
you don't have to do that um you can
actually because of how reticul works
and how it does the integration you can
access those python objects directly
right so in here I'm uh using the create
data frame uh function from python to
add the empty cars and then I when I
pull it up it's not printing the table
like it does before I can show before it
is actually showing you that python
object that's been loaded into SP into
the spark context and then I can access
functions that are part of that data
frame in this case uh correlations for
example right obviously this is not the
way that you will be doing it dat today
but uh you can see that there is no
limitations another way that we can see
that there's no limitations is like when
you extend it with reticulate you can
literally call the same python uh
libraries inside your studio uh context
uh sessions rather uh so in this case
like for something so recent right like
literally yesterday started right you
can go and get your the the ml connect
classification uh library that then you
can start accessing it's uh its
functionality here I'm using the same uh
table empty cars right and and I set up
the um or I prepared for me to be able
to run the machine learning um uh
algorithm and then I run it here and I
fit it I get my uh my logistic
regression and then I can use it to do
the transform which is basically the
predict and I extract the data to pandas
through the T pandas function which
gives me everything um like you know the
predictions here you can see the
predictions directly on the um as new
columns inside my um uh my data frame
which by the way it's already inside R
right so I run all the models out there
and I can get the results back this is
just an example that obviously um we
want for you to use the ml logistic
regression function uh but again once
those features are available we're not
there yet you can access them we're not
locking you out here uh so in closing
spark connect will enable us to be able
to communicate with spark remotely data
braks connect will it has that enable on
dbr 13 and above uh we using uh py spark
to reticulate to integrate that in uh
sparkly R and again we're not limiting
you you can extend it with reticulate uh
here are some links that I'm going to
put because uh I want to thank you first
of all for your attention and here's the
QR if you want to get to this
presentation we will have which will
have all the links that you need thank
you so
[Applause]
much